Parness' other solution is a little bit more subtle.
Now, in this case we're going to coordinate the communication between
the components using a technique called registration broadcast.
Components requiring services which, we're going to call clients, express
interest in state changes in components providing them which we'll call servers.
And that requesting notification is called a registration process.
When a server component announces that something,
detects that something has been changed and announces it, it's going to
announce it to all the registered clients and that's going to be broadcast.
In this particular approach, servers don't know the identities of the clients.
The clients called them and
said, call me back, but I don't know who you are that I'm calling.
And the uni, unit of notification here is the event.
We have essentially the same components as before,
it's just that their mode of interaction has changed, and, and
is now implicit invocation based upon something happening.